l'actualité nous le rappelle trop
souvent et encore ce weekend nous
assistons à une hausse des violences
liées à ces trafic de stupéfiants euh on
voit bien que c'est pour ces
organisations criminelles qui contrôlent
ces trafics un moyen d'assoir leur
emprise ou de l'augmenter en essayant de
de récupérer des marchés qui pourraient
être contrôlés par des équipes rival
c'est aussi une méthode de représaille
qui malheureusement s'installe dans des
logiques devant d'État dont on ne voit
jamais la fin entre groupes entre
groupes rivaux ça se manifeste à la fois
par des opérations d'enlèvement de
séquestration de torture et des
homicides tentatives d'homicide
volontaire dont on peut malheureusement
constater qu'elles s'étendent au-delà
des villes qui les constaté
régulièrement de manière assez strit
assez triste des villes des villes
moyennes de taille moyenne un peu
partout sur le territoire national j'ai
DCI ci de pas vous parler de vous donner
beaucoup de chiffres mais en ce qui
concerne ce phénomène je pense qu'il est
important d'être assez clair pour
montrer le niveau de gravité
exceptionnel de ce qui se passe au 13
novembre 2023 nous avons constaté 315
hicide ou tentative d'homicide entre
malfaiteurs ce qui correspond à une
augmentation de 57 % par rapport à la
même période en
2022 parmi les 451 victimes recensées
puisque un fait peut provoqué plusieurs
malheureusement plusieurs victimes 30 %
on moins de 20
ans et on voit bien que dans certaines
villes je l'ai dit que ça soit à
Marseille à Nice à nî ces phénomènes là
aussi s'étendre au-delà de la périphérie
des villes dans les centres-villes dans
des logiques devant d'État comme je
l'indiquais cette diminution de l'âge
des victimes se retrouve aussi chez les
auteurs où on assiste quand ils sont
interpellés
à un âge malheureusement très faible de
ceux qui qui se livr à ces actes qui
sont sans doute la conséquence d'une
balinisation à la fois de l'accès aux
armes à feu et de l'usage qui peut qui
peut en être faite qui peut en être fait
malheureusement là aussi on a pu le
constater au cours du weekend avec des
victimes collatérales comme ça s'est
passé donc à Dijon comme ça a pu se
passer à nî ou comme ça a pu se passer à
Marseille